Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie - hopefully guys have had a chance to see Rogue One.
A lot of you had Darth Vader questions, and the Lucasfilm people have actually come out and
answered a bunch of them, so this is going to explain
the Darth Vader scenes. There is a new round
of the Star Wars giveaway I'm still giving
away IMAX tickets.
So all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So there were a lot of Darth Vader questions
after this movie.
We arguably the best Darth Vader scene in
any Star Wars movie at the very end, but there
was a lot of questions about the lava planet
where his castle is, which was the only planet
in the movie that did not get a subtitle Everywhere they went,
they had like a little heading that told
you where you were. Part of the reason I think
they chose not to subtitle this, is just to
make you wonder.
So if you're big Star Wars fan, you probably
recognized it and thought about Mustafar
and what that could possibly mean; because that
just blows your mind, like why would Darth
Vader choose to live in a place that represented
so many painful memories for him? And then
there's also the thing you know just where
you see him living on a lava planet, and you're like
"Oh My God, this planet is so hard-core, Darth Vader is so hard-core", so it's just cool from a
visual standpoint, the castle itself just looks bad ass. But here's the deal with that - so like
there are really two huge Darth Vader scenes.
There are a couple of other smaller scenes, but the
two real big scenes were on Mustafar, and
then later at the end when he goes all armistice
from the end a Westworld. So, starting with
the lava planet:
A lot of you guessed (seeing the movie, like I
said) that this is Mustafar, but the Lucasfilm
people that were answering questions about
the canon after the movie came out, just said
that Darth Vader chose this place because
there is so much conflict in him; it's meant
to represent the idea that there's still good
in him.
So he chooses to live here to just punish himself
on purpose - because he's so conflicted.
They kinda did that in a really ham-fisted
way with Kylo Ren during episode eight.
"There's so much conflict in me, you need to help me,
Father, help me choose one side or the other."
So this is Darth Vader doing that same Kylo
Ren thing where he is like teetering on the
edge like he's not completely bad,
but he's not good either.
So just like he is on the precipice, his Castle
is on the precipice of this cliff here with
lava flowing all around.
So it's also a good metaphor for his emotional
state, too. And then of course the bacta tank
is just a visual reference for "Empire Strikes
Back", where you see him in his chamber without
the helmet on, like, "Oh my God what does he look
like underneath all that armor." And for Luke
Skywalker, who gets stuck in the bacta tank.
So there's just a lot of visual metaphors -
like, you don't need a lot of dialogue. I always
feel like the best Darth Vader scenes are ones
that do not involve dialogue - like the one
at the end - best Darth Vader scene in any Star
Wars movie.
He doesn't speak at all.
He just pops the lightsaber and crushes everyone.
So that is why I was a little disappointed
with the dialogue and the puns when he was
talking to Krennick in the base. "Don't get
crushed by the weight of your own ambitions."
I mean, it was a bad ass Vader moment, but I felt
like they didn't need to use the pun. In the
acolyte that a lot people were wondering about -
they're like, "Is this Snoke, here?" Like, "Who is this
person that comes to help him out?"
So this is not Snoke. It's probably just someone
like Donnie Yen's character from a dark side
perspective someone who serves the force but
serves the dark side of the force. More like
an acolyte, but maybe not as powerful as that.
The Emperor has a lot of servants that might
be force sensitive, but aren't dark Jedi themselves.
There was a really cool rumor...
This hasn't been confirmed, but a lot of people
thought that maybe they didn't subtitle this
planet because it's going to come back in
episode eight - because, unless Mustafar was blown
up by the Death Star,
it still exists. It's still out there somewhere.
So we might get to see it again via Kylo Ren's
character as he is training because if he's such
a Vader fanboy, and keeps the melted remains
of his helmet with him at all times, and speaks
did when he also traveled all the places that
Vader had lived.
So Mustafar itself is very strong the dark
side of the force Darth Vader live there for
a long time to just makes sense that Kylo
Ren would either of gone there or we will
go back there through his character as he
tries to complete his Darkside training using
last night's subject to post fuel cells of
the collapse of the place since come to his.
So we have to talk about Darth Vader at the
end of Rogue one versus episode four.
A lot of people are like why is he such a
bad ass at the end of this movie but an episode
for he can barely fight, it's almost like
you super week is almost like he forgot to
fight somewhere in the couple of days that
have gone by between these movies is episode
four picks up just a heartbeat after the end
of Rogue one.
So you know what happened all the skills what's
the deal here, so a lot of this just goes
into the fight choreography and just the way
they planted out is were able to do something
that was technically quite as masterful and
they say that on the set like even Mark Hamill
says when they were fighting with light sabers,
George Lucas was really draconian about how
they were allowed to use them.
They were more like kendo swords the ones
that you wheeled with two hands when they
were on the set of Jedi filming Mark Hamill
said that they were getting ready for the
big final fight they were rehearsing and he
asked Lucas can we just use one hand, we can
actually do a much cooler fight if you let
us use one hand to will the light sabers and
Lucas was like absolutely not.
You have to use two hands.
So it really limited the types of moves that
they could do at the time.
Nowadays Hollywood fight choreography's got
a lot more dynamic is taken inspiration from
a lot of Eastern films so with the evolution
of that as well as the evolution of digital
effects there just able to more fully realize
what Darth Vader should be able to do on screen
so when you rewatch the original trilogy films
just imagined that Darth Vader is every bit
this bad ass but they just were able to do
that when they were actually filming these
movies so it's not that he can't fight it
just that they were able to film at the way
they wanted to.
A lot of you asked about a Darth Vader spinoff
film like if the doing spinoff films.
Why don't we do Darth Vader he's one of the
best characters of all time, I definitely
agree with that statement and I think the
best explanation for why were not can you
get a Darth Vader spinoff film is that final
scene.
It just so amazing so brief, so Vader is best
when he's use like that in a very scarce way
just bits and pieces you can bring them in
he'll do something super creepy super bad
ass you guys can let me know how do you want
them to continue to use Darth Vader in the
future spinoff films.
If there set during the original trilogy timeline.
The next film is about a younger Han Solo
arguably if they don't change the timeline
that would be happening like a couple years
before the events of Rogue one knee that Anakin
Skywalker would've been Darth Vader for at
least a couple years.
He was anointed Darth Vader about 19 years
before the events of Rogue one CF remember
that Han solo's gonna be 26 in his film or
in his mid-20s than Darth Vader would be in
his mid to late 30s, just because that's going
to be Han Solo movie.
I'm not expecting to see a whole lot of Jedi
or anything like that but because it's happening
before the death Star is built Jedi has been
destroyed there might be like a few Jedi floating
around I'm not expecting to see any light
sabers or anything like that okay religions
the nationwide internal measured a blaster
for Steve Jedi flow from one side of the galaxy
the other seen a lot of strange stuff, but
nursing anything I can believe there's one
all-powerful force controlling everything
is no mystical energy field controls Midas
all a lot of simple tricks and nonsense true
let me know how you want the saga films like
episode eight episode nine to continue to
invoke Darth Vader.
I'm not expecting to see Anna cannon's force
ghost, anytime soon most of the Darth Vader
that the films have invoked have been through
Kylo Ren's character so that really just comes
in the form of him staring at the melted helmet
with weird atmospheric creepy music in the
background so hopefully because Ray was retracing
Luke Skywalker steps that she was trying to
find him may be will see Kylo Ren retracing
a lot of Darth Vader steps, but I'll say congratulations
to this week's Star Wars giveaway winner grant
Carlson please private message me on the back
and my channel so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started with this
video so will just announce the winner the
next time I post of Star Wars video while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for all my Rogue one Easter eggs and
you can click here for Rick and Morty Star
Wars death Star parody, thank you so much
watching everybody thought five I'll see you
guys tonight!